the president is scheduled to visit the
southern border tomorrow thousands of
Customs and Border Protection agents are
working without pay during the
government shutdown
Matea V Lal is along the border in
Hidalgo Texas now that is just south of
McAllen where the president plans to go
Matea good morning
well good morning you know a lot of
people that live and work here in the
Rio Grande Valley believe that this is
the the ground zero for the immigration
battle you know Hidalgo County is
predominantly blue there are a lot of
Democrats here they haven't elected a
Republican in over a hundred years and
still though everybody here agrees they
do want border security what they don't
want the biggest differences they do not
want a border wall so far nearly a dozen
or so communities here have passed
resolutions against the border wall
however I will say both Republicans and
Democrats here in the valley agree they
do need more funds to support law
enforcement and to handle the influx of
migrants and the biggest difference here
that Trump supporters believe that they
need to fund his plan and it starts with
closing the gaps in the wall that's
already been constructed here the
Hidalgo port of entry is one of the
busiest in the countries in 2015 nearly
two and a half million people used the
pedestrian bridges here to visit the
u.s. and that same year trade through
the port topped a 30 billion dollar so
it is essential that these two countries
US and Mexico work together here along
the border you know we also spoke with
the mayor of Mission another border town
that's about ten miles from where I am
standing this morning he says he's very
concerned wants to talk to President
Trump because the proposed wall could go
through a number of private land areas
here he is concerned how will first
responders get to those people in the
case of an emergency
gale all right Maria thank you very much